oh go read my name back welcome to the
last of learning 100 person this is an
online game wake up wake up
who said that there's no more time this
looks fragile what - okay squeeze
through air I really don't know anything
about this game it looks pretty locked
oh I am afraid now I need to buy my way
out and discover where the hell I am
damn dark I should find some light
that's a good point there's some light
over here it's too hard to unlock diodes
boy god damn it I wonder that enemy what
the hell whoa are we call are we call
I'd say anything under anything about
anyone
nice chair hell of his chair it seems
very painful
I wonder what happen if I get stuck and
I don't want to know that oh my god a
lot of blood and sharp ideas I don't
want to think what happened here girls
character huh what it's someone out
there hello never what it's too hard to
unlock that it's too hard to unlock Oh
too hard to unlock Oh too hard to hunt
hot to allow to non touch I don't know
what [ __ ] doing all right
I needed some light right and I'm sure
there's total nice laughed blasted maybe
if I grab a just something like I get
this paper wrong or whatever the [ __ ] it
is ah here we go
oh look that is something ever let's
like tool it in you up a dragon and why
do is giant I got out now I can go rear
my god job ID mr. chair
goddammit well I don't know then I don't
[ __ ] know anyone in here shut up holy
[ __ ] [ __ ] creepy man alright let's
check out our cellar or something
well how the hell did I get here in the
first place I'm in quite a pickle right
here nothing inside nothing inside
nothing there we go nevermind our fine
freakin kid damn I need something to
grab it this then
well how about you a fork ah look at
this badass mode I'm Nisha's I'll pitch
it alright it worked just fine I'm
holding an item already press space
sorry pitchfork I'll use you to scratch
my butt later okay all right now it's
money simply inject run and never [ __ ]
me
we should [ __ ] listen ah [ __ ] man I'm
so [ __ ] why did I like bah
oh my god I'm Lissa [ __ ] alright so
that was a pretty fun if you want to
prank your friends I think it's a good
idea to send the link to them
I'll even Lincoln it but I can finish
you enjoy just gotta cover a gelatin
except out Amy Salzburg I didn't know
gum right oh [ __ ] me I realized the game
doesn't actually finish there which is
surprising in my I'm awake gzip it so I
figured I'll finish this thing I'm free
is dogged I'm Sam side I'm still shaking
I'm not kidding and I was [ __ ]
horrible
alright let's get the cake I don't even
want to know what else nice fungus don't
look back guy got butt scratcher
happening I wish care before I want you
yeah I'm a little scared
thank you about crafter like run
all right never look behind
I live in nowheres written but I feel
fairly certain I should not look for not
look at me I not look man never take a
how you done parents care to get just
get blog about it every few weeks
thank you Miss Gaia pretty car shut up
back there alright so this is a loading
I think ah [ __ ] me huh shut all right go
oh shut up okay all right we are [ __ ]
good power but missing something what
need something there wait I can ski okay
it's a new key I'll see you later brah
hey someone's let's keep going again
what the hell is force fields kind of
energy oh come on if someone don't know
all right
Wow
anyone yeah [ __ ] my life I am holding
that more ready and what the hell is
this I don't know I'm singing my song to
be happy everybody is happy shout out la
everybody is dropping Keith later bro
that's it yes I don't know it shut up
well shut door door door door door yeah
sure bro it kind of looked like there
was a fusee thingy
maybe I knew ketover this Elvis no I
hope this light doesn't run out I will
be a very sad beauty patch
whoa it's Bartok ain't no fun like
feedback Bernie Bernbaum phone alright
forcefields you're out of my way now
it's light and beautiful outside
hi it's not that bad forceful is filler
though
so doing that doesn't really do much
let's go in here what was the trailer
like this okay okay let's see here I
died before completing my ritual of
exercise the girls just killed me and
now I'm part of this freaking half
goddamn you house it sucks
well if something's reading this
complete the ritual and leave it's a
baby I made some herbal things to finish
it I cut some people in phases meet your
needs our sense of human to bring like
failing and eco well you're like the
door you'll take their responsibility
whoa
someone kind of telling me to take a
piss well I don't know how to get rid of
the forest wheel oh the force field is
gone over here call no it's not gone at
all I'm an idiot
haha they're phasing the floor
whoa bro are you okay man
what yeah hey bro you look kind of weird
your head is kind of big and your pants
are too big too
oh well the pedestals a sport for the
body part and all the entities we steal
from a half father the Patels it says
you can only feel what's in front of you
hey wait flavor ingredients son makes me
relax cool what are you
it's know why of card how you doing bro
hey Patti how you're that I do you want
your nose back bro is that it no maybe
we touch we feel there we go
all right so I need to collect all the
body parts I guess [ __ ] me I will get
your body parts bro ah which one is in
here probably and what is that a penis
ah god damn it's a finger well what the
[ __ ] are you doing man I'm trying to
help you don't check ding all right well
I can just click my way through
uh all right there go and then
not cool man not cool
I know why they let you have the light
it's so much easier now all right
first feel good crying baby with her mom
you suck mom you suck them all right got
your toy ha ha ah you cry whoa stop stop
ah I got it tight oh shut up
alrighty then now we will put the little
toy come on man you don't want to toy
hey sir why was he shot
why was one toy I like the nose it's so
small a knife what what the [ __ ] what am
I supposed to do with this do you want
it who wants a toy oh maybe the baby the
baby I'm so stupid I'm sorry man I just
[ __ ] off sorry baby baby baby
I'll engineer live man oh no dad ha ha I
can't even talk
ah [ __ ] me we're back here I really
don't want to play I don't know okay
we're back
I found a tongue it was laying right
there that's pretty good
what have you been doing with this time
if you know what I mean I should call
Donna all right what to say
you can only feel what's in front of you
all right it was that one good good
hey Matt how you doing cool huh it's
nice to meet you
you seem like quite the handsome nice
and kind of lock all right now just
gonna give the baby the toy I'm not a
condom I baby you want this good you
good you good you good you go could you
go yes ha ha I got your air badge now
Ron ha ha whoa
oh that close by itself I will not be
going there call I should be here and
then we only need you can only feel
what's in front of you the eyes it's the
eyes right hey man
it's the eyes right I think so I think
it's the eyes all right I think there
was like a shut up
stop knocking noise so 2001 I don't know
when this game with me I think yeah F
force field is still here now it's gone
that's good mr. shott mr. Schad what are
you doing here what are you doing later
ah never listen
hey man hater I got tonight
whoa whoa uh missus yeah stop breakdown
said this is not a barrier baby I get
outfit or what the [ __ ] man
stop it I can't have it all right hey
yeah right in my face
output so I'm polite so freakin I'm
polite
hey happy birthday you go maybe I can do
now I feel all the energy have to sing
along or something is that what it
now I got the eye haha alright I think
we need the eye scan again the powers
huh normally just died the power
well I can't pick it back
[ __ ] this game seriously
hey either nice midday
Oh
go down here check out
[ __ ] long it's session erased totally
should have made this into two parts
cute why did you why did you jump out at
me
there we go
ah
I'd open I don't like it I like it I
love out
alright where's the I [ __ ] everlasting
man
come back in yeah hey I have let you
down there I can't put you down there so
I guess I'm linked with you what's your
name man
ie that's Jay add Nick watch it
[ __ ] stylist what the [ __ ] alright I
made it I think
huh how about that
yeah
yeah
I think sighs yes and right again like a
video just gotta come Richard and I'll
see you next episode I'm a Salesman
should I tell you
hi hey whoa another one
[ __ ] ha ha ha ha ha ha ha